jeetu miss b7 miss battleship the newest
movie that comes out that's a Hasbro
movie that has to be made into a movie
because of the toy lining anyone
merchandising and all that Taylor Kitsch
hich Taylor Kitsch always talks like
this cuz he's overly serious and macho
it's about a fleet of battleships who
get into a battle against an alien race
who we're not sure if he coincidentally
land on earth if it's on purpose the
plot really never explains that to you
you got Taylor Kitsch in the movie and
he's like this burnout naval officer guy
who at first when he first started the
movie he's not he's like he's even more
of a burnout and then yeah eventually he
gets involved with Brooklyn Decker not
terrible to look at no no it starts off
in a bar I'm not gonna give anything
away but it really to me I like the
first scene without that first scene I
would have been like okay this is just
everything takes place on a battleship
the first scene kind of like senator
part made it like a comedy on its own
almost Liam Neeson is her father and he
wants to propose to Brooklyn Decker but
Liam Neeson is also a very a senior
officer his senior officer instigating
obviously you know is afraid of him he's
not working out he's failing often and
so the aliens come but somehow the guy
who's failing all the time is almost
promoted he's like three steps under
calf to half but everyone's like oh
you're a failure he's like I didn't get
that I didn't understand that it was
very strange
how did this happen no one knows only
Peter Berg and the guy who wrote the
script know speaking of Peter Burke who
direct directly money down the kingdom
Friday Night Lights
and khakha that's just nasty
Hancock by the way to me this movie's an
sorry I know we know what you like
speaking of Peter Burke he's kind of
like a Michael Bay but he's a better
version of Michael Bay you know you can
actually understand his action scenes in
his movies they have just a little more
substance than they ever gave I can
understand ways yeah I would agree with
that I would agree
and in a way a lot of people have said
this is like transformers in the copying
off of it and I think that's a lot
that's the trailer the movie itself it
is very different from that style of
Trance there's more substance definitely
is more substance and a little bit more
character development a little bit more
yeah you're not gonna go into battleship
ok expecting Schindler's List you're
gonna go into battleship you're gonna
know what you're gonna gay Liam Neeson
is true he is in this movie saving
sailors but not Jews this movie isn't
miss marketed you know you're gonna see
this movie and you're gonna walk into it
most people are gonna be satisfied they
were gonna clap and yeah that was great
a couple days later they won't even
remember it and they'll go home and
watch you know Transformers Armageddon
their Independence Day or well we
redeemed himself after tomorrow or it's
just a big fun movie the mindless stupid
some really bad acting though Rihanna I
think you and I both agreed that she was
very good looking and I she did
something the slow-motion shots running
away just all tucked out in her Navy
uniform even though that the hair wasn't
up to code it was a little boyish well
that makes me feel awkward now I was not
talking to how much I liked it anybody
her acting was atrocious add absolutely
bad I mean I like ground I actually like
her music I like Rihanna I do Brooklyn
Decker like I said nice to look at some
slo-mo running scenes not sad about that
but not believable as an actress I'm
sorry no she's a mannequin on she's
plastic she I think I stick was holding
her up I don't know where they they
inserted it see that's odd that's where
you were don't you dare cut that out
Taylor Kitsch very you know what he was
John Carter in a Navy uniform he was I
will say it seemed like their I don't
know if it was because Peter Berg did a
better job directing him than I
understand it for John Carter there was
like an ounce more of a human in him and
it might have just been the script I
don't at times he actually like laughs
like something was he had a little bit
of human action realism right it wasn't
I'm on Mars look at me jump
oh there's aliens
but here's really my biggest problem
with this movie why battleship why is it
called battleship it's just another
Hasbro line to develop for yes
battleship not much substance in the
game kind of like the movie it's very
obvious it's a Hasbro thing
merchandising can now happen more things
like transformers and I feel like it
could have just been its own movie it
could have been like aliens versus Navy
or something you could just been I like
that title there's nothing really
needing it for it to be battleship
except that is obviously a giant
marketing yeah I mean what's next I mean
Candyland with Adam Sandler that's
actually happening monopoly which was in
post-production at one point yeah I mean
it's all gonna happen when they chutes
and ladders you know it's all gonna be
hard you know how about don't wake daddy
the movie but it's a drama and it stores
the guy who's in a coma for six years he
has a family at home and it's called
don't wake daddy I'd watch that I would
too you know okay you see the trailer
you see Taylor kids going like oh what
is that it blows it know what kind of
movie you're gonna watch that being said
it is corny and cheesy and dumb and
stupid and mindless in there some of the
acting is awful and there's a lot of
plot holes where you're like I don't get
his spoilers but towards the end
something happens where it's like that
wouldn't do anything it's just gonna all
it's all gonna happen it's not gonna I
can't spoil it for you but it's just
they pretty clumsy they act as if
something is now you know yeah but it's
there's no problem gonna be a problem
battleship I'd give it a C+ it's just I
would okay I agree I'm gonna give the
movie I'm gonna give it a b-minus a
notch above a c-plus just because it was
fun it was definitely like a
crowd-pleasing movie definitely just
something to put popcorn in your mouth
too
so yeah that's our review a battleship
if you guys are watching this on my
channel and probably met fluke pick in a
previous video our review of what to
expect in your expect me we're gonna be
doing some new stuff he's gonna start my
return the Jedi skit my channel if
you're watching this check out his
videos he's a cool dude
thank you thank you you're welcome and
as always if you're watching this on my
channel you guys probably already have
but if you haven't you should subscribe
to my channel and get stopping out
[Music]